free ce que est un peintre dans ce qu'on
appelle les post impressionniste
quelqu'un qui est installé un pas qui
vient des états unis qui est installé à
paris au début du 20e siècle et qui nous
livre ici en fait sont
le tableau s'appelle nu dans la forêt où
on voit toute l'influencé qu'a pu avoir
la génération des impressionnistes sur
une nouvelle génération dans les années
1880 90 et qui a su apprécier
découvrirez repos et s'inspirer en fait
des peintures des artistes
impressionnistes comme caillebotte comme
années comme on est comme voir pour
faire en fait leur propre production et
ce sur ce tableau on retrouve dans le
fond extrêmement lumineux cette touche
nerveuse ces petites touches de couleurs
posées les unes à côté des autres qui
sont vraiment très karaté c'est très
typique en fait de la touche
impressionniste et on le voit très bien
ici en fait dans la partie gauche côté
là où on voit des quasiment des couleurs
pures en fait qui sont posés des unes à
côtés des hommes qui évoque un courant
qui est contemporain de cette peinture
là qui s'appelle le pointillisme avec
des gens comme sera ou avec des gens
comme signac qui posait des petites
touches les unes à côté des autres et le
tableau sera constitué en fait dans
l'oeil quand on peut le retrouver ici
une sauf qu'ici les touchons plus large
plus généreuse plus plus grasse et eau
qui sera trash plus à l'impasse de
peinture impressionniste par contre on
voit qu'il a traité le nu d'une façon
beaucoup plus sensuelle il a pris toute
son attention a été concentrée sur le
corps de la femme où on voit dans des
tons nacré gris rosé tout sousse ses
références aussi à la peinture classique
à la sculpture classique mais en
l'occurrence ici à la peinture de renoir
de pierre auguste renoir qui était
extrêmement appréciée à la fin du 19e et
au début du 20e siècle et que coûte
toute une génération d'artistes à à
considérer en fait comme modèle après le
thème de la peinture est intéressante le
nu un nu féminin
vous savoir que le nu en peinture en
fait depuis
les grecs en fait les venus ont des
femmes nues les dieux romains les dieux
grecs romains sont en général ni le nu
et dans la formation d'un artiste à une
étape obligatoire puisque dessiner un nu
peindre un nu comprendre le nu c'est
comprendre anatomy c'est comprendre la
position du corps c'est comprendre les
gestes et les attitudes pour mieux les
restituer ensuite en peinture donc il y
a des dans la formation des artistes
très souvent des coups ont peint des
nues d'après modèle vivant est bon ça
n'a pas été le cas ici mais en tout cas
le nu fait partie intégrante de la
culture picturale en fait du 19e siècle
et de la culture picturale en plus
générale en fait de très nombreuses
civilisations dans le monde et notamment
la culture européenne